I've been pulled
through time between the past
and the present
and the future.
Everything is turning to
That's right.
That everything can
Around and around and around.
And we go.
All right.
Again.
Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
This will be my Full
Loki Season 2
Episode 4 Trailer Video
There's a whole bunch of brand new footage
and Easter Eggs,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
There's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up.
We also have Invincible Season
two episodes.
In a couple of weeks,
I'll be doing episode videos for that.
That'll sort of like replace
Loki after Loki is done.
Careful for spoilers for everything.
Episode three. If you haven't seen it yet,
But Victor Timely,
can you see you're visiting the TVA?
Learning all the things about the TVA
manual he's been reading and all his ideas
are turned into real things, even though
he's a variant of he who remains now.
They wanted to make it very clear
during the episode
when Sylvie was about to kill him,
like he made this impassioned plea to her
that he's become
a totally different type of person.
I can make my own choices.
That doesn't mean
that I'm going
to be exactly like this other guy
that you just killed, that
you think that I am,
that was also meant to show
how Sylvie has grown to that
she didn't just, like immediately
stab him through
he also made the same speech to her
that she'd been making to read
Slayer in season
one since she was a little girl.
Like, why have you been persecuting me
my whole life?
I'm a totally different type of Loki.
I'm not like these other bad Loki
that you've been pruning
heading into the void planet,
She recognized that and was like,
you are different.
You could potentially be a good king,
so I'm not going to kill you.
but now they're also saying
that most of the ideas in the TVA journal
that inspired Victor
timely to come up with all these new ideas
or the same ideas that he remains used
when he created the TVA.
so even though as adults,
they're very different people,
they both came up with the same basic
types of ideas.
So it's
sort of like getting to visit your dream.
like if you were a young inventor
as a little kid
and came up with these cool ideas,
then you visited
what kinda and you're like,
Wait a minute, this is all real.
This is amazing.
you'd imagine that Victor Timely
is just happy to be here.
Like, this is amazing.
also that funny moment where they set him
up as this huge fan boy of Aura Burrows
because he wrote the journal
just like crazy.
Like, I imagined myself
writing these letters of this person.
there's
a scene of them meeting in the trailer.
This person off screen is Victor
Timely in Aura Borrows is also blown away
because he recognizes him.
He looks just like he who remains. Like,
you're the guy that created everything.
You're the one that brought me here.
lot of people also wondering
if Aura borrows
is like secretly a version of Kang
just hiding out.
I don't think that's going to be the case,
but there might be
couple of secrets behind who he is
and how he wound up at the TVA.
it sounds like the way
they're setting it up,
unless there is like some big twist
that we're not seeing here.
That Aura Borrows
was one of the very first people
that he remains brought to the TVA
when he was creating it.
unless the show is lying to us
like misleading us, he's meant to be
the main tech guy, the TVA,
so he understands how everything works.
He wrote the TVA journal, but a lot of
it was based on he who remains ideas then.
It sounds like once they actually began
creating it or borrows came up with
some of his own ideas
and iterated on the technology himself.
So a lot of the technology of the TVA
was also created by Zora Burrows,
which is how he knew
how to write the journal.
so we just sounds like he is
one of the very first people next to like
Wren Slayer Miss Minutes and he remains
who actually started at the TVA.
because he wrote the journal
and he created
a lot of this technology himself
after the fact.
I think he's meant to be about as smart
as the Kings are,
even though Victor timelines
from the 1800s, the whole idea
is that all the King variants are usually
from the 13th century in the comics.
Then they travel back and forwards
to different points in the timeline.
what they might be doing in the MCU,
though, is just changing that
and just say that
all the Kings are born during
completely different periods in history,
throughout the timeline,
and eventually each of them rise to power
in their own universes in their own way.
Then they discover the multiverse
at some point.
So like eventually Victor
Timely would have discovered
the multiverse on his own
if left his own devices.
remember,
in the original version of his timeline,
he was meant to be
he who remains so he remains eventually
did find the multiverse
in his original timeline.
like we heard him
talking about in the season one finale,
but in the season one finale,
this is interesting.
This is where things get
a little confusing, is
he said that he came from the 30th century
so it might just be subtle variations
and each version of the timeline
like when time reboots,
he might be born
during different periods in history,
just depending on
what time loop they're on.
but at some point any of the kings
that are on the council of they discover
the multiverse, they eventually find
the other versions of themselves.
Then they joined the Council of Kings
in the whole idea is he who remains to us
in season one is that they share
technology, making each other
more powerful in their own universes,
enhancing each of their own universes.
a little bit like a bigger version of he
who remains going full back to the future,
too, with the Sports Almanac giving it
to the younger version of himself,
to make himself more powerful faster
in the next version of the timeline
but that's also what created the Nexus
event, causing him to turn into Victor
timely Kang
making completely different choices,
turning
into a completely different person.
So it's a bit of a mixed bag
doing things like that,
There are moments like that
in the comics too,
with like the Iron Lad version of Kang,
who winds up being a good version of K
who wants to work with the heroes
in winds up rebelling
against the other versions of himself
from different parts of the timeline.
a lot of people also wondering if,
like this young version of Kang here
is what Iron Lad
will eventually look like
when he pops up in the MCU
in some different form,
in some different universe.
we might see a version of Iron Lad
at some point, but because we have Riri
Williams
Iron Heart in a bunch of other Iron
Man related stuff,
they might just wait on that.
But Iron Lad is a big young
Avengers character
and they are setting up young Avengers
in the background,
heading up like the next four
or five years.
Iron Heart is going to be
on that young Avengers team.
So I'm just saying that it would be weird
to have like two Iron Man characters
on the Young Avengers.
Like you're only going to have one
character.
there's a new scene of Sylvie
in one of her time, Portal Doors.
But everything around her in this universe
is spaghetti and nothingness.
I think
either her McDonald's branch timeline
universe has completely collapsed here
or is in the process of
totally collapsing.
And she's forced to go back to the TVA
just to survive.
during some of the other scenes.
You see her back in the 1980s
in this record store
and like everything around her
is turning into spaghetti.
So it just seems that the brains
timeline that she's in
is breaking down around her super fast.
In the episode.
Loki and Mobius warned what would happen
if they didn't fix the temporal loom
like the spaghetti ification problem,
which is continue
getting worse and worse and worse,
like you see in a lot of scenes inside
the TVA with Loki turning into spaghetti
in different parts of the timeline.
that's why Victor Timely is here because
he created the temporal loom in the 1800s.
But as he said,
he didn't have the advanced technology
he needed to make it work for real,
even though the design was solid,
based on the model
here, too, with him looking at it,
it looks like for a second
they might be asking
Victor timely to do the spacewalk
in the more advanced mechanical pants,
which is another call back to that joke
from episode three.
These mechanical trousers don't work.
those might have been like a prototype
idea for the spacesuits of the TVA.
but here's the thing with that.
You actually see Loki on the bridge
without a spacesuit on.
I think during the scene
we're also supposed to see him whip out
his full suit of armor in the massive full
horns, like to protect himself.
no idea why
he's on the walkway to begin with.
Without a spacesuit.
Maybe something goes wrong
when somebody else goes out here
and he has to run out to fix it.
Victor, Timely also said that this device
was his life's work.
I think this device is the thing
that they're supposed to add
to the temporal loom
that will help fix it.
the couple, their funny moments with
Sylvie inside that automat with the pie.
It looks like Loki tries
to get her to eat some pie
and she'll eat some key lime pie
just have some fun.
she says that they're not gods
in Loki's responses,
that they are actually gods,
which is not wrong.
They are the gods of mischief,
so to speak.
But even though it seems
that they have victor timely,
which is the person
they need to unlock the systems,
I think the idea is
they won't be completely successful
or something else will happen
because then all the scenes from episode
one where Loki jumps
to the future on accident,
I think those are meant to be scenes
that we'll see in the eventual finale.
everything of the TVA
looks like it's still breaking down,
like the timeline is still collapsing,
So it sounds like something winds up
happening in the last couple of episodes.
Either they're not successful
in fixing the timeline
or has something to do with what
miss Minutes in Wren Slay are doing.
remember.
They kept saying
in the first couple of episodes
that Miss Minutes has administrator access
to everything in the TVA.
Like she can literally do
anything in the TVA
now that she considers herself
an enemy of everybody there,
including Victor timely.
She might just mess with it
because it sounds like
she didn't even care about the TVA
to begin with.
With the TVA was a distraction from her
and King Just being together,
her real goal is to give herself a body
and be with a version of King
that she wants, he
who remains to come back.
That was the person that she was in love
with in she now recognized the victor.
Time was a completely different
person, like,
you don't love me, and you're a completely
different person, so screw you.
hell hath no fury like an AI scorned. so.
Maybe Miss Minutes
has something to do with everything
going crazy
like these last couple of episodes.
It also sounds like
they're trying to set up Wren.
Slayer is one of the villains
for the last couple of episodes.
But here's the thing.
She actually wanted the TVA.
She wanted to take over the TVA
because she wanted to impose her
order over the timelines So she wants it.
But Miss Minutes
doesn't care about the TVA.
That might lead to some division
in their ranks.
Like the enemy of the enemy is my friend,
but only for a short period
until they're at odds with each other.
Miss Menace might wind up betraying
Wren Slayer at some point.
let me know in the comments.
Do you think that Miss Minutes
will actually wind up
getting herself a body Ultron style?
And how are they going to end her story
this season?
Because Kevin Feige
this is actually a pretty huge deal.
He said that there would not be a
cliffhanger at the end of Loki season two.
Hopefully that's not Kevin Bogey saying
they're not going to do Loki Season three
Because it would be cool to see them
do a season set between Avengers
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
After the multiverse,
it started really collapsing it's
meant to set up Deadpool three, Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty in secret Wars.
So there'll be some connections there.
Loki would have to ultimately
save the TVA.
It has to exist
during the events of Deadpool three.
I do think that Ren Slayer will survive
season two, though.
Like, I think they want to keep her around
as a much bigger character.
But we're only about halfway
through the season,
so there's still, like,
a whole bunch of stuff left to happen.
So post
all your theories in the comments below.
My full episode 4 video
will post next week.
Just like normal and Big Reminder
Invincible Season two episodes
will start in a couple of weeks.
I'll be doing videos for that.
I just did a big trailer video, so I'll
post a link down to the description below.
click.
Here for my full Loki Season 2
Episode 3 Video and click here
to learn all about this huge deleted scene
and storyline from Loki Season
two of the Council of Kings
in this giant multiverse war.
They were going to do
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!